something with great pleasure to concrete your
life is the transition with those cells
from mahara stramien je for whom in that
very global teacher prize jonas
coulissen proud owner of the group at
each of price and a word that is so
much to highlight teachers
transform  the light of young people
everywhere i speak to you the
critical moments for education words
where the cali pandemic is delft there is
much exposed education system from the
world by turning crysis me quickly tune in
to learning cats stiff and the ethical
the contribution of teachers  you in this
difficult times
this is mac in the die french lily
henrike na is the hardwork
and sacrifice at they made all the
support
week en glam so fat and help the next
generation find a 14 increasing glenn
kind of answer
teacher's liken tradition in their steps
small  match a be more peaceful
and just a site is teachers fly ride c&a
will eliminate in the quality in drive
floor
economy group teachers la grange t
how do you save our future I think you are very
much